kk getting the start he's one in three
with an era of 3.65
at home he's been good 1-0 1.84
eugenio suarez leads off the 2-2
inside corner and struck him out there's
castianos
the 2-0
castianos
morenato bats up slings it over to first
and makes the play nicely done nolan
arnado
and a one two three for kk goldsmith
back in the lineup luis castillo on the
hill his numbers from western and
southern well he would like to forget
the numbers and i'm sure that he'd like
to just have a nice clean slate out
there there's dylan carlson
swinging at a miss
fastball with life up and away first k
for castillo
nolan ornato so
not carrying the left field the farmer
makes the catch in the shallow grass and
that lead off error stranded reds will
come to bat here in the second inning
with tyler stevenson leading things off
tyler stevenson crushes the first pitch
deep left and that one is gone tyler
stevenson launches the bench loves it
the dugout erupts and the reds on top
one to nothing farmers hit by a pitch
and now jonathan india
jonathan india cranks with a deep left
field that shoots o'neill back and
that's gone
second homer of the inning for the reds
and two out thunder from jonathan india
has the reds ahead three to nothing well
the reds are dialing eight
tonight in
st louis and you talk about a guy that
finishes his swing india does that
i've talked a lot about pitchers
finishing their pitches as they want to
get extra movement on it but india
really used his hands on that pitch
landino is one for his last 16 with
seven strikeouts
second strikeout for kim
a couple of home runs and a
three-nothing cincinnati lead midway
through two
tommy edmond reached on error first time
up 2-2
swaying it a miss
second k of the day for castillo two
down paul goldschmidt at the plate he
lined out to castillano's first time
suarez the short way to second and
devening threads a win in the series
already in hand lead three nothing not
what you want to see and here we go
again as kim
is walking off the mound
went out to warm up chris conroy there
on the right
cardinals medical team and kim coming
off and his night is through
first warm-up pitch
yep you see him shaking his shaking his
leg there hopefully it's nothing serious
cardinals getting bit by the injury bug
wow mike freeman had run for alex
blandino he stays in the game at first
base
glendino's okay hit by pitch on the hand
with a fastball big first baseman's mitt
matt carpenter is lined out to second
his outings and perspective that one
hung a bit india slides and makes the
catch
jonathan india is having himself a night
and it's at the expense of matt
carpenter
nothing wrong with that that one a
little bit of a change up line drive
gave indy a chance to move over to get
it but he was moving as carpenter was
taking that swing
sosa
bounced into a force
the ball that should have been caught
and that is launched in the first career
major league homer sosa
gets the cardinals on the board and a
long one out to left
and that makes it a 3-1 game
first career major league home run at
mundo
the nissan drive of the game and he knew
it getting the ball over the middle of
the plate and going way back to the
trees right when needed friday night
game was getting a little slow defense
seemed like it was a little sluggish we
needed to score something there sosa
hitting a bomb
shogo akiyama will pinch hit for scott
heinemann
the 01 pitch
get down to the left field line o'neal
is over sliding forward and he caught it
oh my goodness what a play by tyler
o'neill one of the best catches you'll
see this season
the bjc healthcare
difference maker and what a play this is
what a play i don't know about you but
that low wall over there when he was
hauling but that scared me to death the
injuries that we've had what can happen
him sliding there thank goodness he got
up so quick but what an amazing play
knowing exactly where he was on the
field used his leg to plan it against
the wall and stop his momentum so he
didn't get hurt oh what a play
and here is luis castillo a ground out
and a strikeout for the red starter
castillo gets into one deep center field
carlson
retreat and it's over his head and off
the wall
india rounds third he scores a hammer
double the deep center by luis castillo
and the reds lead at four to
one nick castillanos what he's done
against relievers this year oh hit
nearly 400.
castillanos into right and man
cannot make the play nick castellanos
are standing double and that's a 20-game
hitting streak for the hottest red i
mean you talk about an emphasis i mean
this pitch is right on the outer part of
the plate little
i don't know it was a slider maybe a
little backup slider
he just takes that pitch to the other
way
castellanos the double in the seventh
that stretched baseball's best hitting
streak to 20 games
that is smoked into right field long run
for edmond that falls fair and skips
into the stands that'll be another
double the second of the day for nick
castellanos second and third one out now
the cardinals will pull their infield in
for tyler stevenson
infield in
and that is stroked into left gets down
base hit winker scores castellanos to
third
another rbi for tyler stevenson and
padding for the reds
five one in the ninth
moment of the corners
infield back double play depth fernandez
to second
that's all castillano scores
and the reds are out of slam range it's
six to one
here's carpenter over three tonight with
a strikeout two and one to count on matt
carpenter
and he drives that into the gap in left
center you'd rather see that
in a misplay by winker
carpenter to second base
o'neill will score and it's now a 6-2
game the reds lead in peril
three runs in two on two out ninth
inning paul goldschmidt do up michael
feliz is on
swing and a miss in the dirt stevenson
gathers completes the put out and the
reds win it survival in the ninth and
the reds have taken the first two and
see louis a 6-4 finish tonight